plenty of snow for our spring mounds
today and more is on the way as a winter
storm warning does continue
sally jeremiah continues our team
coverage with how things looked from up
in the mountains sally
brian it's a winter wonderland up here
definitely
a sight to see as you can see everything
looking
so beautiful however a lot of people
want to come up here but you must take
precautions conditions where i am right
now
in the lower elevations as you can see
some snow
coming down pretty hard right now but
once you go up
you definitely need those chains and
that four wheel drive now
areas of kyle canyon and lee canyon are
experiencing snow conditions
and that had many families heading up
here early to be
safe people i spoke with say they packed
blankets extra clothes
food and water they were anticipating
this snow
from snowball fights to snowmen to snow
angels
we saw it all
yeah everything's looking good just the
you know fog of it
is the driving and making sure there's
no one in front of us
but besides that everything seems good i
don't have any chains that's why we only
stayed in this little low area if you go
higher you need the chains we did see
snow plows on the roads
and law enforcement turning cars away
that were not equipped to handle snow
a reminder again if you do plan to come
up here you are required that four-wheel
drive
and those chains if you're looking to go
to the higher elevations we are
expecting
more snow accumulations by tomorrow
morning as that winter storm warning
will continue